hey man I was thinking maybe we should
like hang out sometime grab a beer a
brew engineer or something together
I'm picnic doing sports that's stupid
okay whatever I I got this wish me luck
five tips to a more productive defi
number one listening to music that's his
own and sends a message to co-workers
that you are not to be bothered okay huh
could do this it was just a friendly
softball tournament so there's nothing
really riding on it now I still think we
need to cover the first place
row I'm comfortable with that Harper and
Kaylin are in Oh Charlie played baseball
in college oh how do you know that his
wife's Facebook oh he doesn't have a
personal Facebook so sometimes I go
there for updates uh if so we should ask
him to play then right that is a great
idea Adam I was just gonna ask him to
coach me you mean coach the team you are
full of ideas today number two learn how
to say no it's all about setting
boundaries and prioritizing prioritizing
isn't a word dude Charlie we're setting
up a softball league we want you to play
shortstop no but what if we offer you no
I hear what you're saying I'm gonna veto
no please do this for us no I know I
will right charlie an email leave a
paper trail
everything should have a paper trail
dear charlie
bromance hope all is well best Elliot
now we wait number three only check
emails at the end of the day you gotta
tell me twice I rat Helen we're starting
a softball league
you're the shortstop but it doesn't
Charlie play shortstop not anymore
I can't play shortstop thanks for
cooperating I can play team mom
number four drink more water you got it
hey man you're gonna get coffee or no
cool I hate coffee
si zebra you're right mr. Harris
I don't deserve something as special as
a bromance
Elliot mom Han like to ask you earlier
you busy this weekend the weekend never
perfect you want to grab a beer I would
love to have a picnic with you
picnic okay yeah you know what screw it
let's do a picnic we'll talk about it
later I gotta run to the bathroom I'm
drinking water all day so like water
come on you knew it you're doing it
I usually cry when I play sports all
right thank you very much see you on the
field
you